I feel like with thats good enough yeah
like the one that the Internet's talking
about today is that love is in the air
young love Keith Davidson the stand-up
comedian you know from SNL Ariana Grande
she's a singer she's a pop star they
just got engaged after only dating for
24 days what do we think do you guys
believe in love at first sight what do
you think yeah yes I do I believe I
don't believe it works out there and
good for them they were at Disney World
right there's somebody who is miss work
to go to Disney very romantic and very
fun even though it's a place for kids
there's lots of love there and you know
you were an adult at Disneyland I'm
suspicious
it's celebrating like if I was in love
with someone like so much and then they
proposed to me at Disney I would be like
[Laughter]
it's like especially because Pete
Davidson Ariana Grande are like powerful
rich celebrities and you have all that
money and you're like yeah I'm gonna go
to the place covered in toddler boogers
this is their like public celebration
and then they're doing the secret line
elsewhere but they got to give something
to their
twenty-four days have a couple name yeah
we should give that to them Davidson
grande Davidson hashtag grande Davidson
please credit us if you use it sounds
like a lawyer have you been hurt
recently in a traffic accident would you
propose to somebody at Disneyworld do
you want to say they did not propose at
Disneyworld they got engaged and then
went there to celebrate would you know
that's so great so weird if I were rich
I'd go somewhere else but I think some
people some rich people like to cosplay
as middle-class let's pretend we can't
afford something better than this this
is entertaining interesting as a married
man I'm going to say it took me six
years
and I still was suspicious of my wife
international pop star
I don't think Ariana's going after I
love thinking about Chris five years
into relationship just really suspicious
[Laughter]
my very long con the very long con did
you admire the commitment I admire the
fact that he can make a commitment 24
days
I am also terrified but then Hollywood
goes he'll be the one able to die old
well why don't we why don't we think
about the fat Hollywood goes celebrities
are like dogs they you know one years
like seven years 24 days what about the
fact that on May 9th it became public
that Mac Miller ariana grande's ex and
her broke up recently broke up both of
them relationships now they're engaged
[Laughter]
his wife after six years does in fact
like know that you were this suspicious
or she finding out like when she's
watching this now I think she proudly
was on to me so that's that's Chris
Kahn's recommendation don't get engaged
after 24 days be very suspicious of each
other for six years and then if both of
you are still alive maybe propose and
get together yeah thanks fact here's a
different thing that we're gonna do
right now
[Music]
hey I'm Chris Kyle what anybody do here
thanks y'all couple of hypothetical
questions I'm gonna get shot what y'all
would do I'm gonna tell you what I want
to did this is what I want to do I'm a
white Detroiters on Comedy Central and
June 21st season two starts go check it
out okay Hannah it's on Detroiters Tim
loves a good hot dog here's the question
what would you do if a fool gives you
gas in public I do carry gas X in my
purse so it's just yeah well also you
just walk around so you like the Batman
of gas you got like a look crowds are
the best all right what I would do what
I do do what I do when I get my gas what
I would've did I just you know some
anything else
public I have to embrace it because
somebody yeah you don't know that
sometimes that gas can scare you your
nose in the backseat because you might
be driving check it out make sure it's
Nereo clear all right
joy all Detroiters Sam becomes a male
escort hmm what would you do on a first
date with a prostitute
okay so I have hired this person in the
scenario or it's it's just
coincidentally they're a prostitute
that's her I'm not here to tell you
[Laughter]
I'd probably just take them out to
dinner and have a nice conversation with
them there are also people presumptuous
that they're people what I would do
[Applause]
Detroiters wigs we're using dead human
hair later they used that animal fur
okay here's a question what would you do
if you discovered you were being fed
roadkill what would I do if I discovered
he's being fed road captain truly so
many questions okay I guess you're gonna
provide no answers right okay I guess
I'm gonna assume maybe it's at a fancy
restaurant surprise and find out it's
roadkill yeah I would be very upset and
I would send the food back that's what
you do this is what I would do delicious
roadkill I don't want to know what it is
because then I would I don't want to be
searching out roadkill you're gonna be
in the streets of it what a night just
just roadkill blood coming down the side
you're saying you get addicted to the
road oh I'm definitely gonna dig the
road listen if fried you fraction at
some point was technically wrong killed
right somebody fried I believe this is
delicious now you seek it out you don't
want it found out that they're muskrat
is delicious this deer is technically a
roadkill take blue one now you see
people out there hunt
I think the hunting came before no no no
starting from Rokia that's not a
question I have this week this was what
I would've did hey my name is Natasha
and I'm a style freak all I care about
is fashion what's trending today I'm
gonna catch you up on the hottest trends
and the color of the week is pink
specifically the shade of pink and
watermelon linked to over 60 salmonella
poisoning yeah don't worry the company
responsible for distributing the
Mellon's Kaito Foods has recalled the
fruit but I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say melon toes are gonna be the it color
of the season that's because sonny
perdue the Secretary of Agriculture and
the guy rubbing his balls all over your
Cabbage Patch has guided the fg8 to
reverse animal welfare protections and
food safety regulations Savage so when
planning your wardrobe stick with Browns
blues and grace to offset your jaundiced
skin and eyes from the salmonella
poisoning we're all gonna get hashtag
Salmonella akin to stop me from looking
fly hell M van Gogh's third party for
your read the accessory of the week is
earmuffs this fuzzy and colorful
accessory is gonna provide the perfect
Flair and protection if you're anyone
who's anyone and by that I mean
specifically anyone who is an American
diplomat in China the US State
Department recently evacuated at least
two diplomats out of China actually
experienced headaches nausea and
cognitive impairments after hearing
strange unidentified sounds kind of like
how I feel after going to a Skrillex
concert am i right if this fashion is
giving you deja vu you're right girl
the exact same thing happened to US
diplomats in 2016 in 2016 US diplomats
in Cuba heard strange noises got super
sick and we're evacuated hashtag TBD
which means earmuffs are here this day
but this simple accessory you can turn
your look from drab to fab
please don't hear poison me with your
mystery sounds yes we yours
she must have is peep toe sandals
because your toes are little pervert and
that's my trend report I'm Natasha and
all I care about is trends great are we
breaking for lunch cool I got to heat up
my tilapia fish is only good hot tell us
if you like hot fish in the comments
please I wanna hear from all of you
[Music]
rehearsing before it before name like we
all like a little jitter whatever I know
it's like going to the makeup room and I
caught Nate like coming out of there
like out of there like with the cards
and he was just going like Kim jong-un
supreme leader I think I just ended up
saying supreme leader I think I didn't
even try I don't think I tried by
screwing up
[Music]
you